US Attorney John Durham is conducting
his own investigation into the origins
of the Russia probe after today's IG
report came out Durham cook a rare step
of issuing a statement saying as Molly
too suggested that he disagrees with
several of the report's findings in
particular about why the Russia
investigation began
Stephanie Grisham is of course the press
secretary at the White House and she
joins us tonight severy thanks so much
for coming on
so as you assess this report what jumped
out at you well people need to be held
accountable this was a government trying
to overthrow a president by falsifying
documents and by lying and and by
ruining the lives of many many people so
I think for a lot of people watching and
you hate to have people become more
cynical the more news
they ingest but it's hard not to have
that happen people are wondering like
you know no one's gonna be indicted when
law enforcement agencies destroy
American citizens on the basis of no
evidence for political reasons that they
get away with it how does it happen I
don't know I mean it's it's been a
chilling effect to read the report and
to see everything today has been
chilling and with Durham I would think
he's gonna look into it more and we'll
see what happens there people who are
supposed to be enforcing the law took
the law into their own hands and that's
really scary and there needs to be
people held accountable not just the one
FBI attorney who falsified documents
against Carter page who was working with
another agency absolutely people need to
be held accountable what's so troubling
about all of this is that even if as the
report claims politics were not behind
these screw-ups hmm and it was just a
purely a political series of dishonest
steps the FBI remains the FBI with
awesome power people are still getting
investigated by the FBI can we trust
that the FBI is on the level I guess
that's the most important question well
as the president has always said there
are great people working in the FBI hard
working people but people at top levels
need to be looked at and they need to be
looked at all the time they have great
power as you just said and so it's very
very important that we really look into
this we find who is responsible and
there are absolute there's there's
something that happens right
consequences do you believe it's likely
that the Attorney General mr. Barr will
be firing some people I hope so I can't
get ahead of him I'm not going to
knocking especially I want but I
certainly hope so this is again this is
a chilling effect and the American
people need to believe that the FBI the
CIA all of the intelligence
organizations in this country are to be
trusted and the fact that for years now
there has been an effort to overthrow
this president it's it's scary and it
shouldn't happen any president I don't
care what party you're in yeah and that
a lot of the media is cheering them on
cheering him on constantly Stephanie
great to see you thank you so much
homework